[Music] It
is said that the diameter of the structure is 0.02 mm, and we are the only one who can put it on the sheet
.
I think it can be said that it is the thinnest Japanese paper in the world
. My
name is Hiroshi Chinmae.
We make a special Japanese paper called Tengujo paper using the structure of the raw material. It
is said that it has a history of more than a thousand years, starting from the Mudani century, and the
knowledge necessary to make this special Japanese paper has been passed down from generation to generation.  First of
all, the structure of the raw material is procured from a farmer.
And I have Shigeta Principle
[Music]
After that, I crush it into thin pieces
and mix it with water and Nelly to make a sheet. The
finished hair is highly transparent.  However, because it is formed because of its long length,
it is a characteristic of the god that it is strong
and supple to some extent.
It can be widely used in libraries and museums, etc.
Famous places are the British Museum, the
Library of Congress in the United States,
and even in Japan, the National Institutes for Cultural Heritage, Tokyo National Museum
.
I think it's a job that I'm proud of to the people I'm working with and the people who will take over this job in terms of taking on challenges.